Prof: Let's get started.
Welcome to the parents who've
made it today.
Thank you for sending us your
bright people to pay our
salaries and learn from us.
We've spent most of the
semester so far figuring out
what bond is,
and how quantum mechanics
works, and so on.
But now we're trying to find
out how it really happened --
how people discovered how
chemistry in general,
and organic chemistry in
particular, worked.
And we started with Lavoisier.
And now we're in the next
generation, which is Berzelius
in Sweden.
And, as we said last time,
he was important for analysis.
He got good atomic weights for
fifty elements.
We'll talk today about
electrolysis and dualism.
He was important for his
teaching and writing.
For the first half of the 19th
Century he was the main man in
chemistry;
and his notation for
composition that we talked about
last time, that we still use.
Okay, so now we're going to
talk about atomic weights and
equivalents and what was
involved there.
We started this last time;
remember, showed how Gay-Lussac
had an alternative to Dalton.
There was this question about
what,
even if you knew the proper
ratios of elements,
what you didn't know was the
ratios of the atoms that were in
them,
because you didn't know whether
an atomic weight should be
doubled or halved.
So they had the question about
Silicon Chloride,
was it SiCl,
SiCl_2.
SiCl_3, SiCl_4?
So how could you possibly
settle something like this?
Dalton did it by assuming that
if you had only one compound,
it had to be one-to-one.
Gay-Lussac went with the
volumes of the gases that were
involved,
which turned out ultimately to
be correct,
although it wasn't really
widely accepted for about sixty
years.
But there was another neat way
of doing it, depending on
crystals.
Mitscherlich,
an Austrian,
had this device on which you
mount a crystal and reflect
light off it through a
telescope.
So when you do that,
you know precisely --
if it comes right up the middle
of the telescope,
you know exactly what direction
the plane of that surface of the
crystal is.
So what you can do then is
rotate it by a certain number of
degrees,
until some other face of the
crystal reflects precisely,
and then you can measure very,
very accurately what the angle
between those two faces is.
So that was crystallography,
in those days,
before X-ray.
Okay?
So here's his paper on
"Relating Crystal Shape to
Chemical Proportions."
They sound like not closely
related phenomena.
But here's he's talking about
arsenates and phosphates.
And here, the pictures he drew
-- they drew beautiful pictures
of crystals in those days;
if that's all you can do,
you do it right.
But he saw that those crystals
were the same shape for
corresponding arsenates and
phosphates,
this diammonium biarsenate and
the diammonium biphosphate.
Right?
So he measured the angles.
And here's his table of the
angles corresponding.
And you can see they're very,
very close to one another.
Those are the differences in
tenths of degrees.
So these crystals are precisely
the same.
Now what could he conclude from
that?
Anybody got an idea,
where you can go from here?
So you know that there's an
arsenate and a phosphate with
the same chemical composition.
Right?
And they give exactly the same
shape.
So the things that pack
together must be exactly the
same.
So they must have the
corresponding number --
however many arsenates there
are --
arsenic atoms there are in one,
there must be exactly the same
number of phosphorous atoms in
the other.
Otherwise they could not
possibly be exactly the same
shape.
So now you know something.
There was this need for
relative atomic weights.
Was Dalton right?
Was water HO?
Or was Gay-Lussac right,
that it was H_2O?
Right?
At least in this case,
this thing called isomorphism,
the same shape of the crystals,
provided definitive atomic
weight ratios for at least some
of the atom pairs.
So arsenic atoms must play
exactly the same role in
arsenates that phosphorous atoms
play in phosphates.
And therefore,
if you have 100 grams of
nitrogen,
oxygen and hydrogen,
that combines to give these
salts,
with 30.64 grams of
phosphorous, or 78.11 grams of
arsenic,
it must be that arsenic atom is
2.55 times as heavy as the
phosphorous atom.
Right?
That is, it can't be half that,
or twice that.
It has to be exactly that,
because there have to be the
same number to give exactly the
same shape.
Okay?
So there was one way of
determining this ratio.
But it wasn't trivial.
Okay?
Now here's Berzelius's Table of
atomic and molecular weights
from the year 1831.
And if we zoom in on it a bit
here,
you can see he gave two columns
for the atomic weights,
one based on oxygen being 100
units,
and the other based on H,
with a bar across it,
being one.
Now, the bar across atoms means
that the atoms are doubled.
You can have it without a bar,
which is a single atom;
or the bar across,
that means it's a doubled atom.
So he had -- actually you
notice, if you can go down the
column there,
that if you assume H_2 as 1,
then obviously H here is a
half.
Right?
So these were the numbers he
had in 1831.
And we could compare them with
what they would be nowadays,
if you scaled to oxygen,
as we define it now,
to be 15.9994.
And then you see that they're
off by about 1%,
up or down.
How does that compare with what
Dalton was getting?
Do you remember how accurate he
was?
He was about 10%.
So here in twenty-five years
they've gotten tenfold more
accurate in what the atomic
weights are.
Okay?
Now, combustion analysis was,
and would continue to be,
from the time of Lavoisier,
right through the whole
nineteenth century,
the heavy carrier for organic
chemistry.
Okay, here's the way Berzelius
did combustion analysis.
So he started with a tube in
which he put half a gram of
organic substance that was going
to be analyzed,
three grams of sodium chlorate.
Remember, that's what
Gay-Lussac used to burn things
with.
Why that rather than air?
Why did Gay-Lussac use it
rather than air?
Do you remember?
Because a lot of things
wouldn't burn in air,
right?
They would char.
Okay, so but they used
Gay-Lussac's oxidizing agent.
And fifty grams of sodium
chloride was ground up with this
stuff, just so that the reaction
wouldn't get out of hand,
so it wouldn't explode.
Okay, so those were put in
there.
Then he heated up the neck and
drew it out, and plugged it into
that bulb on the right.
Right?
So he joined it to that bulb,
which would serve for
collecting water,
which is a combustion product,
and a calcium chloride drying
tube,
which would get the rest of the
water that didn't condense in
the bulb.
Okay?
Then he assembled this thing
along the bottom so that the
gases that came out,
after the water was removed,
would exit and be collected in
this bell jar,
over mercury.
And in that,
there was a bulb that floated,
which held potassium hydroxide;
solid potassium hydroxide,
which would absorb the CO_2,
thereby separating it from the
oxygen that would come through.
You get oxygen just by heating
sodium chlorate.
Okay?
And then he closed the top with
a piece of glove leather so that
mercury,
that it was floating on,
couldn't --
little drops of mercury
wouldn't get in.
Because, as you know,
from hefting it,
that would change the weight a
good deal.
Okay?
So what he did was build a fire
and move that barrier back,
so it would heat from one end
to the other,
and the gases would come out
and bubble up in the bell jar,
and fill up a good deal of the
bell jar.
Right?
And notice that the tube had
been wrapped with metal to keep
it from popping when it got hot
in the fire,
because there'd be pressure
inside in order to bubble
through the mercury.
Okay, so then he cools it off.
The gas contracts. Right?
The KOH absorbs CO_2.
So you're left with oxygen in
the bell jar,
and the CO_2 is absorbed on the
potassium hydroxide.
But he then -- so the mercury
rises as the gas gets absorbed.
But after the mercury stops
rising,
he waits twelve hours to make
sure he's got all the CO_2
absorbed,
because it has to get through
the glove leather,
right?
So it takes quite a while.
It took much more than a day to
do an analysis.
So after it stops rising,
he takes it apart,
takes the glove leather off the
top, weighs it,
and finds out how much CO_2
there was.
So he's got the water and the
CO_2,_;
therefore the hydrogen
and the carbon.
And this was a much better way
of doing it than Lavoisier's,
which required three or four
people operating that big
machine.
Okay.
Electricity was another really
important contribution from
Berzelius.
Okay?
But it also was a contribution
at the Royal Institution in
London where -- this is a
demonstration of N_2O at the
Royal Institution.
But the guy holding the bellows
there is Humphry Davy,
who became the head of the
Royal Institution,
and was the head then of big
science.
So in 1807 and '8,
he made some very important
experiments.
It was based on the work of
Volta, who was just a little
more than a decade earlier,
who had invented this thing,
shown on his desk here,
which was the Voltaic Pile,
which was a pile of copper and
zinc discs.
And when you put copper and
zinc together,
you can get 1.1 volts out of
it.
Okay?
So this was going to be big
science.
So he put together twenty-four
such pairs of things,
which meant he could get
twenty-six volts.
Those were six inches square.
Right?
Then he made another -- there's
the battery, incidentally,
that Berzelius had,
which is still in Stockholm.
Okay?
Then he put one with 100 such
things, so he could get 110
volts.
Then he made another one.
They were only four inches
square.
Now 165 volts, right?
And then he could hook them
together in series.
So he could get 301 volts
across this thing.
And then he tried doing
experiments with it.
So this is what he said:
"I acted upon aqueous
solutions of potash and
soda…."
You know what potash is?
Student:
>
Prof: Potassium
hydroxide, and soda is sodium
hydroxide.
"…saturated at
common temperatures,
by the highest electrical power
I could command,
and which was produced by a
combination of voltaic batteries
belonging to the Royal
Institution,
containing twenty-four plates
of copper and zinc,
twelve inches square,
100 plates of six inches,
and 150 of four inches
square."
So this is that battery I
showed you.
So he put
300-and-whatever-number of volts
across this thing.
"Though there was a high
intensity of action,
the water of the solution alone
was affected,
and hydrogen and oxygen
disengaged with the production
of much heat and violent
effervescence."
I can believe that.
And so he wasn't about to give
up.
He tried again.
"The presence of water
appearing thus to prevent any
decomposition,
I used potash"
(so potassium hydroxide)
"in igneous fusion."
(So he put a flame to it and
melted it.)
"By means of a stream of
oxygen gas from a gasometer
applied to the flame of a spirit
lamp,
which was thrown on to a
platina spoon containing potash,
this alkali was kept for some
minutes in a strong red heat,
and in a state of perfect
fluidity.
The spoon was preserved in
communication with the positive
side of the battery"
I don't know how he held this
thing.
>
"of the power of 100 of 6
inches, highly charged;
and the connection from the
negative side was made by a
platina wire.
By this arrangement,
some brilliant phenomena were
produced.
The potash appeared a conductor
in a high degree,
and as long the communication
was preserved,
a most intense light was
exhibited at the negative wire,
and a column of flame,
which seemed to be owing to the
development of combustible
matter,
arose from the point of
contact."
Right?
Then he did another experiment.
"A small piece of pure
potash,
which had been exposed for a
few seconds to the atmosphere,
so as to give a conducting
power to the surface,
was placed upon an insulated
disc of platina,
connected with the negative
side of the battery in the power
of 250 of 6 and 4,
in a state of intense activity;
and a platina wire,
communicating with the positive
side, was brought in contact
with the upper surface of the
alkali.
…small globules having a
high metallic luster,
and being precisely similar in
visible characters to
quick-silver..."
What's quick-silver?
Live silver, right?
Mercury, of course.
Okay?
"…some of which
burnt with explosion and bright
flame,
as soon as they were formed,
and others remained,
and were merely tarnished,
and finally covered with a
white film which formed on their
surfaces."
What was this?
He electrolyzed -- here he says
potash, potassium hydroxide.
What did he get?
Student:  Potassium.
Prof: Potassium metal.
So he discovered a new element.
And from soda he got sodium;
from potash he got potassium.
Okay, now this was a great
triumph for English science.
But this was a period of great
rivalry, 1807 and ‘8.
The Peninsular War was going on
in Portugal, Spain,
against the French;
in particular, against Napoleon.
Now Napoleon had studied
science a certain amount as a
student at the École
Militaire in Paris.
In fact, he had been examined
by Laplace, Lavoisier's
colleague in measuring heat.
So he wasn't about to knuckle
under to England in this.
So he got his crew together,
including Gay-Lussac,
and said, "Why haven't we
discovered this?"
And Gay-Lussac said,
"We don't have the
battery."
He says, "You've got your
So this was the battery that
Gay-Lussac constructed
accordingly.
* So it
consisted of 600 one-kilogram
copper plates and 600
three-kilogram zinc plates.
So he had 2.6 tons of metal and
in six different troughs here.
And then he hooked them
together in series.
>
So he's now got 650 volts.
Now, Napoleon was interested in
science.
So he came to visit the lab one
day.
And there's an account of this
in the biography of Humphry
Davy.
"With that rapidity,
which characterized all his
motions,
and before the attendants could
interpose any precaution,
he thrust the extreme wires of
the battery under his tongue and
received a shock,
which nearly deprived him of
sensation.
After recovering from its
effects, he quitted the
laboratory,
without making any remark,
and was never afterwards heard
to refer to the subject."
>
Okay, so that was the end of
the French competition with
Humphry Davy.
But Davy himself built one with
1000 plates;
so 2200 volts.
And with this he was able to
prepare a bunch of elements.
In addition to sodium and
potassium, boron,
magnesium, calcium and barium
were all due to Sir Humphry
Davy.
But that wasn't really the most
important thing for chemistry.
It supplied more than new
elements, it supplied an idea,
and the idea was the organizing
principle for what was called
dualism.
And dualism was the idea that
there were things that were
positive and things that were
negative, and they would be
attracted to one another.
Not only would they be
attracted to one another,
but they could trade partners.
Okay?
So remember we saw last time
that the alchemists already had
vitriolum cupri,
or copper sulfate.
So here we saw last time was
copper sulfate.
Let me see if I can get this
thing going here There we go.
So there's copper sulfate,
nice and blue.
Let me get the light behind,
that should be good.
Okay, so we'll put some in here.
So this is copper as a positive
stuff, and sulfate as negative
stuff.
And now we'll take sodium
hydroxide, and put a little bit
in.
So there's a precipitate.
And actually it's much more
complicated than people thought
it was in those days.
It gets quite dark blue of you
put a lot in there.
But now a whitish precipitate
is going to form,
which you don't see very well
here;
maybe it doesn't know how to
focus on that.
So it needs something for it to
focus on.
There.
There you see the precipitate.
Okay, so obviously something
happened.
Right?
And according to Dualism,
this is what happened.
Right?
You mix it with caustic soda
and you have AB and CD;
positive and negative on the
left, sodium hydroxide,
copper sulfate,
and they change partners,
and you get a precipitate.
So you have -- and it's
explained by electricity.
And this then is what dualism
was.
So, notice that this is our
family tree, you'll remember,
and now we've looked at
elemental analysis,
atoms and dualism.
Notice that people are entered
into this,
not by when they made their
contribution,
because they made it at many
different times,
but by when they were born.
So you can see what the
generations were.
So first we had Lavoisier,
then Berzelius.
And now we're into a new
generation of people who are
going to contribute when they
get to be 20,30-years-old down
here.
So the next thing we're going
to talk about is urea and
isomers, and the benzoyl
radical, and the theory of
substitutions and types.
Okay?
And our players are
Jean-Baptiste André
Dumas, in France,
and Liebig and Wöhler in
Germany.
And they were all born right
around 1800;
between 1800 and 1803.
Okay.
And here they are on the
outside of the building.
So we're going to look at
Wöhler and Liebig.
Now, here's Wöhler,
writing to Berzelius in Sweden
--
he's going to be the next
generation --
saying, "Having developed
the greatest respect for you
through studying your writings,
I have always thought it would
be my greatest good fortune to
be able to practice this science
under the direction of such a
man,
which has always been my
fondest desire."
Those who have seen such
letters will recognize that
these as consistent up to the
present day.
He goes on to say:
"Although I earlier had
planned to become a
physician…".
Okay?
And at the end he says,
"With the greatest
respect, Friedrich Wöhler
from Frankfurt am Main."
He was a great guy.
They carried on a
correspondence their whole
lives;
it's really entertaining,
partly because Wöhler had
sort of a lame-ish sense of
humor and was a cartoonist.
So, for example,
in this letter to Berzelius in
1837 --
so this is ten years later --
he said,
"To see this old friend
again,
especially here ,
was a real delight.
He was just the same old guy,
with the sole exception that he
no longer wears the little
toupee swept up over his
forehead as he used to do."
So Wöhler drew this
cartoon in there.
Okay, but what you know
Wöhler for,
probably, is urea.
How many people have heard
about Wöhler and urea?
Okay.
But the interesting thing is
that the urea was not the main
contribution.
He also invented aluminum
incidentally,
or discovered aluminum.
But urea wasn't really the
main, for our purposes,
wasn't the main contribution
from this work of Wöhler.
And you'll see that there are a
couple of problems for next
Wednesday, and readings on the
web that support this,
with original documents.
So he wrote in 1828 to
Berzelius: "Perhaps you
still remember the experiment I
carried out in that fortunate
time when I working with you,
in which I found that whenever
one tries to react cyanic acid
with ammonia,
a crystalline substance appears
which is inert,
behaving neither like cyanate
nor like ammonia."
So that's what was funny,
that it didn't behave like you
would expect for ammonium
cyanate.
So the idea was it should be a
double decomposition reaction,
this dualistic thing,
where you change partners.
So you start with ammonium
chloride,
silver cyanate -- that was
another way he did it --
and you should get ammonium
cyanate and silver chloride,
which is a precipitate.
So then you've prepared
ammonium cyanate.
But you can test whether
ammonium cyanate is the
salt ammonium cyanate.
One is to see whether it has
the ammonium ion in it,
and that you can tell by
pulling the proton off and
changing it back into ammonia,
which you can smell.
Okay?
But when he treated it with
sodium hydroxide,
he didn't get ammonia.
Okay?
Or you can test…
So it doesn't behave like an
ammonium salt.
Nor did it behave like a
cyanate salt.
If you treat it with acid you
don't get the smell of cyanic
acid.
And if you treat it with lead,
you don't get lead cyanate.
So it appears not to be either
ammonia or cyanic acid anymore.
Okay?
But what it did do,
when treated with nitric acid,
was to give brilliant crystal
flakes.
So the crystals were what
allowed him to identify it.
And he knew that you got the
same thing when you treated urea
with nitric acid,
just like those from urea and
nitric acid.
Right?
So this raised a question.
Berzelius wrote to Wöhler,
in reply to that:
"It is a unique situation
that the salt nature so entirely
disappears"
--
it doesn't look like dualism
anymore --
"when the acid and the
ammonia combine,
one that will certainly be most
enlightening for future
theory."
So might ammonium cyanate
actually be urea?
Might urea be ammonium cyanate,
with very curious properties?
So Wöhler wrote back to
Berzelius: "I recently
performed a small experiment,
appropriate to the limited time
I have available"
--
he was doing a lot of teaching
at this time --
"which I quickly completed
and which,
thank God, did not require a
single analysis."
That was what was a pain in the
neck to do.
So this is the data from
Wöhler's letter,
and the same thing was
published as his paper in 1828.
So it turned out that
Dr. Prout,
a physician in London,
had already analyzed urea,
and reported its composition in
terms of nitrogen,
carbon, hydrogen and oxygen;
that is, its ultimate analysis.
And Wöhler,
without doing an experiment,
knew what the analysis should
be for ammonium cyanate,
because he had Berzelius's
atomic weights.
So he could calculate for a
substance of that formula what
the percent by weight should be.
And they agreed,
as you can see,
very, very well.
So it looked like urea and
ammonium cyanate had the same
analysis, and therefore were the
same thing.
Okay?
The discrepancies were less
than 2%.
Remember, the atomic weights
were only good to about 1%.
Okay, so therefore these things
appear to be identical.
In fact, it's interesting to
compare them with the modern
values, which you see here.
What do you notice in the first
row?
When you compare the numbers in
the first row?
Russell?
Student:  It seems like
they're much the same.
Prof: What's the same?
Student: The nitrogen
and --
Prof: Which is better,
experiment or theory?
Student:  They're the
same.
Prof: What?
Student:  They're the
same.
Student:  Experiment is
better.
Prof: No,
no, the first is Prout's
analysis, the first column;
the last column is
Berzelius-Wöhler theory;
and the middle is what we think
is correct, because it's based
on what we have now.
What do you say?
Student:  The experiment.
Prof: Ah ha!
so there's a good lesson for
us.
Right?
Experiment is better than
theory.
But if you look more closely,
there's a much more interesting
story here.
So the moral is don't dry-lab;
don't be like Lavoisier and try
to make your experiments conform
to theory.
Right?
So, because of that,
Dr. Prout has a gotten a
reputation among historians of
science as a paragon of accuracy
and honesty;
the very model for lab work.
Right?
Okay, but let's look more
carefully.
You notice, for example,
that he didn't make these
things add up to 100%.
Would you expect them to --
what would happen if it had been
Lavoisier doing it,
what would they add up to?
Student:  100%.
Prof: 100%.
Exactly.
Here it isn't.
Why not?
Student:  Being honest.
Prof: Because he's been
honest; maybe.
>
Okay.
So notice, incidentally,
that the theory didn't add up
to 100%.
Now how do you get those
numbers?
How would Wöhler have
gotten those numbers?
He decided how many atoms of
nitrogen, hydrogen,
oxygen there are in the
compound.
He'd see, according to the
atomic weights,
how much each of those would
weigh.
He'd add them all together.
That would be the total.
And then he'd divide each one
by the total to get how many
percent it was.
Is that clear to everyone,
how you go about it?
So how do you do that and not
get it to add to 100%?
Well I recalculated it,
using Berzelius's numbers,
and that's what I got.
Now you'll notice a couple of
things here.
One, here, you'll notice what?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: That he just
truncated numbers,
he didn't round them off.
Right?
So it's always going to be low;
and indeed it is low, his sum.
But that's not low enough.
Right?
What else do you notice?
Angela?
Student:  He switched
them in the last --
Prof: He switched the
numbers in the last row.
He made an error.
But the important thing is he
didn't notice he made the error.
He added it up and saw that it
was 99.8, and thought,
well what the heck,
it's 99.8.
Because this was early days of
doing this kind of stuff.
Okay?
Now, so we come over to
Dr. Prout.
Is this experimental candor?
Well you find out,
if you add the numbers,
it's actually 99.945.
>
He added wrong.
Okay?
And now, but those things
really agreed.
Right?
Now you wonder,
how did old Dr. Prout do
this, to measure it to 1 part in
5000?
Right?
It turned out he measured the
volume of the gas,
and what he reported was 6.3
cubic inches of gas.
Right?
So was he just lucky that it
happened to be right to four
significant figures?
No.
Because that's not how he did
the experiment.
What he reported was not
actually experimental.
He had a theory about atomic
weights.
His theory was that everything
was made of hydrogen;
which isn't so far wrong in
terms of weight,
right?
Because a proton and a neutron
have the same weight.
A proton is hydrogen.
So everything is the sum of
protons and neutrons;
for weight, the electrons don't
count for much.
Right?
So it's not actually such a bad
theory.
So in his system,
carbon was six,
oxygen eight,
nitrogen fourteen;
you know, that was what integer
you multiply them by.
Incidentally,
hydrogen was called
protyle,
from, let's see,
from (hyle prote,
which means the first
substance.
Okay?
So he had this theory.
So what he did was do
approximate analysis,
get about what the ratio is,
figure out what the ratio
should be,
in terms of small whole
numbers, and then multiply them
by his atomic weights.
So these numbers are not really
experimental numbers,
they're more like Lavoisier.
All right?
So what he said was,
it was one, one,
two, one, and that gives those
numbers.
Okay?
So Prout did dry-lab by
making an approximate analysis
and reporting results corrected
by his theory.
And so much for the paragon of
accuracy and honesty,
as far as we would see it.
Okay, but his theory was better
than Berzelius's experiments.
That's interesting.
Okay, so now ammonium cyanate
to urea.
Let's review that,
from the point of view of what
we've been talking about.
So you have ammonium.
What makes it reactive?
Dana?
Student:  High HOMO.
Prof: High HOMO or low
LUMO?
Student:  High HOMO and
--
Prof: It's got a
positive charge.
That's one clue.
Anybody got an idea?
John?
Student:  A low LUMO.
Prof: And what do you
suppose that low LUMO is,
in terms of localized orbitals?
We're not going to talk about
things that go over the whole
molecule.
There's not much to deal with
here in ammonium.
Yoonjoo?
Student:  The LUMOs from
the σ*,
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  The LUMOs from
the σ*.
Prof: σ* of
N-H.
Okay, so that'll be the LUMO.
How about a HOMO on the other
side?
Student: Unshared pair.
Prof: There's a hint.
Okay, the unshared pair on
nitrogen with a negative charge.
Okay?
So we've got these,
and we can do the
make-and-break trick,
attack the σ* with
that.
Right?
So we've gotten back to ammonia
and cyanic acid,
a possible starting place for
getting there.
But if you have these two
things, you could react them
with one another.
What makes ammonia reactive,
NH_3?
Student:  The high HOMO.
Prof: The high HOMO,
the unshared pair.
And how about the cyanic acid?
What do you see there that
looks like a functional group?
Don't worry too much about how
big it has to be,
just see something that looks
familiar.
Prof: C=O double bond,
π*,
right?
Okay, now so we can -- so one
of these can attack the other,
and we can arrange them like
that and draw a curved arrow.
And we could attack the C=O
double bond.
But you could also attack the
C=N double bond.
And, in fact,
these aren't so different,
because when you attack one,
and make an unshared-pair on
the other,
in this case,
for example,
that high HOMO on the nitrogen,
the N^-, can be stabilized by
mixing with the π* of
the carbonyl.
Right?
So you could actually draw it
either way.
So it really doesn't make any
difference which way you draw
it, at the beginning.
But what you can do is then
have a further reaction,
the HOMO on the bottom reacting
with the σ* again;
although they probably can't
line up right,
within a molecule.
It's probably one molecule
attacking another molecule to do
this.
Okay?
And get the hydrogen transfer.
And that is urea.
Okay, so there's how you go
from ammonium cyanate to urea.
It's quite an easy chain of
events.
You could've done it the other
way too, like that,
and you'd get this compound.
But those molecules,
the urea and this one,
can lose a proton,
go back on, lose,
go back on, one side or the
other, and ultimately you get
the one that's more stable,
which is the one that has the
carbon oxygen double bond;
which is a very stable
grouping, as we'll learn later,
in terms of lore.
You can actually understand it
in terms of HUMO and LUMO mixing
here too.
But at any rate,
that's what happened.
So the question arises,
can ammonium cyanate exist,
or does it always change?
Is there such a salt,
or does it always change to
urea?
And in fact Dunitz,
our old pal and your
great-uncle,
in 1998, with Kenneth Harris,
did an X-ray structure that
showed that you can have
ammonium cyanate.
This was the first time it had
ever been proved to exist.
And there's what it looks like.
But notice, the nitrogens,
on the ammonia there,
point toward oxygens,
not toward nitrogens.
So it's not -- from this
arrangement, you couldn't have
done that thing that we -- the
mechanism that we drew in order
to get from here to there.
Okay, so but the fact of
getting urea,
a product of animal metabolism,
from purely (as far as they
were concerned inorganic things,
which is said to have done away
with the idea of vitalism,
was not, from my perspective,
the most important contribution
here.
Because this is what
Wöhler wrote toward the end
of that paper,
in 1828: "I refrain from
all considerations which so
naturally suggest themselves
from this fact,"
--
that is, that ammonium cyanate
and urea have the same analysis
--
"especially in respect to
the composition ratios of
organic substances and in
respect to similar elemental and
quantitative compositions among
compounds with very different
properties,
as may be supposed,
among others,
of fulminic acid and cyanic
acid."
We already did those;
that was a problem early on
when we were drawing Lewis
structures.
So two different arrangements
of the same atoms.
"…and of a liquid
hydrocarbon and the olefiant
gas."
The olefiant gas,
the gas that will "make an
oil", is ethylene,
CH_2CH_2.
But that's very similar to the
-- that's exactly the same ratio
of atoms as you have in a long
hydrocarbon, if it has a
double-bond in it.
"It must be left to
further investigation of many
similar cases to decide what
general laws can be defined
therefrom."
Now this is an interesting
point, because when people have
certain tools available,
they tend to think that that's
all the tools that could be
available,
and therefore it gives all the
information that's possible.
Right?
So if what you can do is
elemental analysis,
you think that once you have
the ratio of the elements,
you know everything about the
substance.
But what he shows here is that
there can be different
substances that have the same
elemental analysis,
like urea and ammonium cyanate.
So the possibility of isomerism
showed there was more to be
known than people thought,
when all they could do was
elemental analysis.
So fulminic and cyanic acid was
very important,
as we'll see in just a second.
Now Berzelius wrote a paper
just two years later,
in 1830, "On the
Composition of Tartaric
Acid" --
remember we spoke before about
how pervasive tartaric acid is
in the nineteenth century in the
development of organic
chemistry--
;"and Racemic
Acid" --
also called John's Acid from
the Vosges--
;"on the Atomic Weight
of Lead Oxide,
together with General Remarks
on Substances that have
the Same Composition but
Different Properties."
So he found that tartaric acid,
and this John's acid from the
Vosges, also called racemic
acid, had exactly the same
analysis, their salts did.
Right?
And here, in fact,
is a picture of it.
I have the actual stuff right
here.
This is from a cork from a wine
bottle, and on top of it here,
if we're lucky -- see.
You can see those,
and that's -- we took one of
the crystals and put it on the
X-ray.
There's what they look like.
They're beautiful little
crystals.
And they're calcium tartrate.
So remember,
you get -- tartaric acid grows
from tartar on the walls of the
wine barrels.
But this is what was important.
He wanted to give a name for
this phenomenon,
things that had the same
analysis but were clearly
different.
"I thought it necessary to
choose between the words
homosynthetic and isomeric.
The former is built from
homos,
equivalent and
synthetos,
put together;
the latter from
isomeres,
has the same meaning,
although it only properly says
put together from the same
pieces.
The latter has the advantage
with respect to brevity and
euphony."
So it's shorter and it sounds
-- it's easier to say.
So from now on we're going to
choose "isomer"
to talk about this phenomenon.
"By isomeric substances,
I understand those which posses
the same chemical composition
and the same
atomic…."
By that he means molecular
weight, but different
properties.
Okay, so that's where
"isomers"
came from.
So it showed there was more to
be discovered.
There must be something about
how these pieces are put
together that's different.
But how can you possibly find
that out, just by doing
reactions and weighing things?
Okay?
Same chemical composition but
different properties.
Okay, so there's more to
chemistry than the analytical
composition, which is what they
were good at measuring.
Now we know the importance of
atomic arrangement,
or structure.
So there are four Cs that we'll
organize things about it:
Composition,
Constitution,
Configuration and Conformation.
But you've got to be patient.
It'll take a little while to
get there;
it was several more decades.
Okay, now these isomers of HCNO
have been calculated to death in
2004, and we actually did a
problem set and showed these
earlier on.
But here's what they are.
There's cyanic acid.
And notice, this is the same
anion, but you pull the proton
off one end and put it on the
other.
It's somewhat less stable,
but they interconvert easily.
Okay?
There's the one,
when you put nitrogen in the
middle.
It's considerably higher.
That's called fulminic acid.
And if you put the hydrogen on
the other end of that one.
Now the bottom one is what
Wöhler was working with,
but the top one was being
studied by the other guy,
Liebig;
fulminic acid.
And the name comes from,
which means lightening.
Because like so many young
lads, Liebig enjoyed things that
would blow up.
Right?
And he blew the window out of
the pharmacy where he was
serving as an apprentice.
Right?
And then he went to Gay-Lussac,
to work on silver fulminate,
which is not great stuff to
work on, as people who know from
fulminates know.
But anyhow in 1824 he was in
Paris working on that.
And Gay-Lussac noticed the
paper from Wöhler on the
analysis of silver cyanate,
and saw that they had the same
analysis.
So he got them together,
Gay-Lussac did.
Now notice -- and we're going
to talk much more about the
interaction of those two guys --
but notice in this portrait of
Liebig that there's a device
down in the bottom right.
Remember, people,
when they got their portraits
made, always put something they
thought was significant there.
So this is what he thought was
significant.
And here it is.
It's not the actual one.
This is made by our glassblower.
And you've seen it before.
For example,
you come by this when you're
hurrying to class.
And notice right there,
same thing.
Right?
Or, if any of you are student
members of the American Chemical
Society, that's on the logo.
Because that was the most
important device of the 19th
Century for organic chemistry.
It's called the five-bulb
apparatus, the Fünfkugel
Apparat.
Okay?
And it was used by Liebig for
analysis.
So here's how Liebig did his
And you can see the five-bulb
apparatus here.
So he had a tube,
much like Berzelius's,
in which he put burning
charcoal in there,
and he'd heat it up and
generate the gases,
but on a much smaller scale
than Berzelius did.
Okay, it came through a drying
agent, that collected the water
that was a product.
And then it came in to the
Fünfkugel Apparat,
which was the CO_2 collector.
So in here was sodium
hydroxide.
Right?
And the way it worked was it
was tilted a little bit.
You notice that it's propped up
here, with some pieces of wood,
so that the bottom isn't flat.
It's tilted like this.
Okay?
So the gas comes in.
And because it's tilted,
it bubbles from one to the
next.
Right?
So it mixes well and absorbs.
So you don't -- remember,
Lavoisier needed a couple,
a guy standing there to stir
those things so that the
CO_2… This was
self-collecting,
right?
And then at the end you cool
the thing off.
Now notice -- what do you
notice about the bulbs here?
Student:  The size.
Prof: They're different
sized.
And you had to put it this way,
not this way.
Why did you have to do it this
way?
Because what happened at the
end?
You stopped the fire,
and it would suck back.
So this had to be big enough to
hold all the liquid.
This one didn't.
So they were a different size.
You don't want to make both of
them big, because you want to
keep it as light as possible.
It was made out of very thin
glass.
So there's only one that still
exists, that Liebig had.
So it was tilted for the reason
we said.
And here's the original one,
which is still in Giessen,
in Germany, where he was a
professor then.
Right?
But this was a great advance
because,
with this, a single student
could do three analyses in a
day,
rather than Lavoisier's big
machine that required four
people working forever;
or Berzelius's,
which required waiting
overnight for the CO_2_
to be absorbed all,
and so on.
So this was the most important
thing.
And everybody,
all the students,
who wanted to be organic
chemists, went to learn how to
do this, in Giessen.
So Liebig is almost everyone's
great-great-grea
t-great-great-wh
atever-grandfather in chemistry.
Because all the people who went
out to teach studied how to do
this with him in Giessen.
So here's a portrait,
a little bit later portrait,
of Liebig, after he had gone to
Munich to be a big wheel.
And but again he chose in his
portrait to have a picture of
the Fünfkugel
Apparat.
But if you look at it
carefully, you see something
very interesting.
Do you see what it is?
As far as I know,
no one ever noticed this
before.
It's hooked up backwards.
How can he possibly have hooked
it up backwards?
He must've told hundreds of
students over the years,
"Look, when you put it
together, you put it this way,
not this way."
It's like which tube in a
condenser you connect to the
water.
Right?
>
It's exactly the same kind of
thing.
Right?
So I just think that's amazing,
that he didn't notice that.
But anyhow.
There we got it backwards.
Okay, this was his teaching
laboratory, which still exists
in Giessen.
It's a museum.
It's interesting to go there.
And there's,
on the wall,
there's this thing,
and it shows all of his
students and grand-students and
great-grand-students who became
distinguished professors,
and the ones in red are ones
who got the Nobel Prize;
the ones with red on them.
And you could extend it now.
This stops in the middle of the
20th Century,
and practically everyone's
descended from Liebig,
including you.
Okay?
This is his lab.
And here, this is,
here's Ortigosa,
from Mexico,
and he was supposed to be so
good at analysis that he could
do it better than Liebig did.
Right?
So he's the one that got to
hold the five-bulb apparatus.
And what do you notice about it?
He's holding it upside down;
the potassium hydroxide would
run out.
Right?
And this guy is A.W. Hofmann,
who -- there's this thing of
him: "A master and shining
teacher of chemistry,
a triumphant discoverer of
aniline and aniline dyes."
And he also was the guy that
was really good at languages,
and devised a lot of the names
we use nowadays.
So we'll talk about that later.
And here in the background,
looking through a window into
the lab,
is it looks to be -- I'm not
sure that that's what it is --
but it looks like a bust.
Does it look like a bust to you?
And if it's a bust,
it's probably this bust,
of Liebig.
So there.
>
It's fun to go there.
Okay, so in 1832,
Liebig and Wöhler
collaborated to develop the
radical theory.
And we'll just give an
introduction to that and not go
all the way through it.
So Liebig and Wöhler
remember had been introduced by
Gay-Lussac.
So they were of the same age
and doing similar kinds of
things.
So they first met in Frankfurt
in 1825.
And five years later,
when they were writing,
they first used the familiar;
you know, like the tu in
French or du in Germany,
if you're really great friends
with someone,
or within the family you use
that.
So they became great pals.
And in 1832,
Wöhler said:
"I long to do some more
significant work.
Shouldn't we try to shed some
light on the confusion about the
oil of bitter almonds?
But where to get
material?"
Right?
So Baker, J.T. Baker didn't
exist then.
But if they were now,
they could just order up a
bottle of it.
So can you smell this?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Do you recognize
the odor?
Pass it around carefully,
don't drop it.
>
It's not that bad,
but you don't want to drop it.
See if you recognize the odor.
Like almonds,
the oil of bitter almonds.
Okay?
Okay, so in June of 1832,
just the next month,
Liebig wrote to his pal
Wöhler and said,
"My poor deal Wöhler,
how empty is every comfort
against such a loss."
(Because Wöhler's young
wife had just died.)
"When I think how content
and happy you were during your
move,
what attachment and love you
had for one another…
The good wife,
so young and full of life,
so irreplaceable for her
parents and for you.
Come to us, dear Wöhler.
Although we may not be able to
give you comfort,
we will perhaps be able to help
you bear your grief.
Staying in Cassel at this time
would only be detrimental to
your health.
We need to be busy with
something.
I have just been able to get
some amygdalin from Paris,
and I am ordering 25 pounds of
bitter almonds.
You must not travel,
you must busy yourself,
but not in Cassel.
I haven't had the courage to
tell my wife yet."
>
"Come to us,
I expect you at the end of this
week."
No, what he didn't want to tell
her about was the death of
Wöhler's wife,
obviously.
Okay.
So then in July Wöhler
says it came:
"The oil of bitter almonds
has come with the books from
Paris.
I've kept half of it and am
herewith sending you the rest.
I've already started all kinds
of experiments with it,
without being able to obtain
any precise results.
It seems to be a hard nut."
This is an example of
Wöhler's lame sense of
humor.
He did this all the time.
"I'm coming soon to you
and will be able to
report."
So they worked together for two
weeks on this and developed the
most important theory,
on the basis of these
experiments.
Wöhler returned.
He said: "Here I am again
in my gloomy lonesomeness,
not knowing how to thank you
for all the love with which you
took me in and kept me for so
long.
How happy I was to work with
you from moment to moment.
Herewith I'm sending the paper
on oil of bitter almonds."
So next time we'll talk about
what they did with their oil of
bitter almonds.